[Musique]
et c'est l'heure de notre large page
sport dans le 7 8 avec notre journaliste
sport de la rédaction de tv78 Mickaël et
midoro François vous êtes de retour et
on va parler forcément pour commencer de
football c'est notre image sport du
week-end elle concerne la Coupe du monde
de football qui se tient en ce moment au
Qatar deux images prises pendant le
match de l'équipe de France ce dimanche
à 16h face à la Pologne la première
image dans un bar de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye un bar bondé pour
soutenir l'équipe de France les
supporters en fait beaucoup de bruit à
chaque but et l'ambiance était bonne
enfant ils étaient environ 150 dans
l'établissement et quelques autres en
terrasse l'autre photo a été prise après
le match de Voisins-le-Bretonneux en
dernier district contrôles FC Mantois
les vices chinois ont filé directement
voir la rencontre après le coup de
sifflet final aux alentours de 16h30
c'était d'ailleurs le cas pour beaucoup
de joueurs à des Yvelines tous sports
confondus les matchs étaient programmés
pour la plupart aux alentours de 15
heures au total
14,32 millions de Français ont regardé
cette victoire de la France contre la
Pologne ils seront sûrement encore plus
nombreux ce samedi à 20h face à
l'Angleterre l'Angleterre moi
malheureusement le match était à 15h
donc j'ai raté une partie du match
nos invités d'ailleurs sport sont
revenus en plateau avec ces lyonnaise et
son coach René et bami vous y croyez la
victoire de l'équipe de France
bien sûr j'espère après je suis étudié
entre la France et le Portugal n'empêche
et face à l'Angleterre vous avez pas
peur c'est juste quand même une équipe
un peu plus relevée on va dire qui se
présente pour les Bleus mais ils sont
prêts donc je pense que bon ils vont
faire une bouchée
dans un instant de la très belle
médaille de bronze d'Axel Duriez qu'il a
obtenu au championnat du monde ce sera
dans un instant on va poursuivre avec
les résultats sports du weekend et on
continue à parler de football toujours à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux ont joué donc ce
weekend en Dr de district comme je l'ai
dit précédemment voisin le Bretonneux
recevait l’équipe 3 du FC Mantois les
vicie noir ont remporté ce choc une
belle victoire de 1 sur leur terrain et
qui fait du bien au classement le voisin
FC monte sur le podium l'équipe est
troisième avec 15 points et distant son
adversaire du jour le championnat est
toujours dominé par lime et qui caracole
en tête avec 20 points et 6 victoires en
8 journées comme toujours mais le
championnat national 2 voici repart de
l'avant après une défaite contre Racing
colombe 92 la semaine dernière les
pistes se sont imposés 2-1 sur leur
pelouse face à Vannes les buteurs Amadou
Konaté et check Touré à la 77e minute
après 12 journées disputé Poissy et
deuxième avec 25 points et le club peut
toujours espérer monter en fin de saison
on jouait également sur les terrains de
régional de plusieurs matchs étaient au
programme ce week-end trap c'est imposé
2 à 0 sur le terrain de l'ES parisienne
de zéro également pour l'équipe de du FC
Mantois sur son terrain contre Garen
Colomb Conflans gagne 2 1 face à adamoa
Poissy 2 s'impose 3-0 face à Champigny
enfin grosse contreperformance de
Houilles défait sur son terrain face à
Ivry US 2 sur le score de 1 à 0 le
championnat est toujours dominé par
Argenteuil Conflans et deuxième et
Houilles et 3e le rugby et le
championnat de fédéral 2 ça jouait ce
dimanche dans ce championnat de Fédérale
de plaisir qui veut monter en fin de
saison a perdu le choc face au harassé
sur le score de 21 13 contre-performance
qui les empêchent de rester sur le
podium ils sont 5e à l'heure actuelle de
son côté Versailles perd d'un petit
point sur le terrain du Rheu 28 à 27 les
Versailles sont 7e le basket que
s'est-il passé sur les terrains de
national de féminine en National de les
féminines du chêné à Versailles se sont
imposés à ces fascinant sur leur parquet
face à Saint-Amand Hainaut Basket le
score 68 à 54 une victoire qui permet au
Chesnay Versailles d'être toujours à la
quatrième place du classement le bilan
de l'équipe 6 victoires et 4 défaites
depuis le début de la saison on termine
avec du cyclisme sur piste et j'ai envie
de vous dire cocorico cocorico
effectivement championnat championne du
monde en titre de vitesse individuelle
la française Mathilde gros qui
s'entraîne presque quotidiennement au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans divine a
remporté ce samedi soir à Londres la
Ligue des champions de cyclisme sur
pistance sprint elle devient la première
française à s'imposer dans cette
compétition disputée en cinq étapes la
sprinter 4 des 5 manches loto française
Marie divine quoi mais ce classe 9e de
l'épreuve la Ligue des champions qui
pourrait revenir l'année prochaine au
vélo de national de 50 ans en Yvelines
elle avait d'ailleurs assuré l'ambiance
un MATIF de gros la semaine dernière au
vélo national en remportant cette manche
justement de vitesse individuelle au
Vélodrome national merci pour suivre
pour les pages de 2024 l'un des visages
français à suivre pour ces JO de Paris
bien sûr à domicile avec ce vélo drone
national on continue cette édition avec
un très beau résultat vous en disait
quelques mots au début du 7 8 c'est du
tumbling il est licencié aux
Clayes-sous-Bois et Axel Duriez vient de
remporter la médaille de bronze au
mondiaux de Tumbling c'était à Sophia en
Bulgarie nous avons la chance de l'avoir
en compagnie je le disais de son coach
qui est infidèle du plateau on a le
plaisir de le recevoir souvent René et
Bamy qu'est-ce que ça vous fait d'avoir
cette médaille de bronze vous êtes venus
avec d'ailleurs autour du cou ça vous
fait quoi Excel bah ça fait un très
grand honneur déjà puisque c'est
toujours un rêve de gagner face au plus
grand ou même de faire une médaille face
au plus grand aujourd'hui j'ai pu faire
cette médaille se battre certains grands
que j'ai toujours rêvé de battre puis
donc pour moi c'est un rêve
oui j'ai réalisé oui parce que
à chaque fois que je fais une
compétition assez importante dès que le
résultat est tombé je passe déjà à la
prochaine je pense déjà au prochain
compétition qui arrive donc réaliser oui
j'ai dû à réaliser mais je suis déjà sur
mes prochains objectifs c'est pas un
aboutissement pour vous c'est peut-être
la suite d'autres choses mais vous
l'avez fêté quand même cette médaille
rassurée
j'ai fait un peu la fête avec tout le
monde toute l'équipe de France toutes
les personnes qui étaient là et puis en
rentrant chez moi j'ai vu ma famille et
tout le monde m'a félicité et René
est-ce que vous avez fait la fête vous
bien
qui
non je suis très fier parce que je
pensais qu'elle arriverait beaucoup plus
tard le plus tôt que prévu donc voilà
donc elle était inattendu donc dans ce
cas là enfin on fait encore plus la fête
parce que on se dit ben voilà faut
profiter on ne sait pas quand elle sera
la prochaine 17 ans c'est bien ça
absolument c'est le plus jeune de la
compétition et je crois que c'est la
première médaille masculine pour le
dueling français si je dis pas de
bêtises depuis 2001
est-ce que vous réalisez justement côté
entraîneur côté athlète directement
celui qui a fait la performance Axel moi
je réalise oui puisque c'est optus la
dernière personne qui a fait une
médaille au championnat du monde c'était
c'est le kiné qui m'a accompagné sur
cette compétition donc Nicolas Fournial
qui du coup c'était une joie de fêter
cette médaille avec lui sachant que
c'était le dernier album c'était le
témoin
pendant le la compétition donc c'était
vraiment assez symbolique cette image
vous le suivait et derrière bah voilà il
a ramené aussi médaille donc le passage
de témoin est assuré vous en tant
qu'entraîneur quel regard vous portez
sur cette performance et justement cette
première depuis 2001
une très grande fierté et
Axel surprendre de jour en jour parce
que je pense que même si moi je me
paraissait très très difficile lui aussi
officine mais dans Au Coin dans un coin
de sa tête je pense que il avait en
ligne de mire d'avoir une médaille il se
dit rien n'est impossible il a raison la
preuve il a il est moche mais moi c'est
vrai que je ne je l'envisageais pas ça
tout de suite donc là d'avoir fait ça
enfin à qui accepte avec depuis que je
suis depuis qu'il a 11 ans bah toutes
les compètes qu'il fait il revient avec
une médaille n'arrêtait qu'une seule
sortie internationale il a raté que en
catégorie 15 16 ans ou en plus c'est pas
une erreur vraiment technique c'est
parce que la piste est un peu trop court
pour lui
dépassé
la dépasse la réception pour la dernière
envole mais sinon à chaque fois qu'il a
levé le bras pour se présenter ben
chaque fois il sortait avec une super
performance donc bah je pense que voilà
il a c'est un grand
championnes aux anciennes performances à
vous n'aviez pas encore la petite
barbichette qui est apparue sur notre
visage mais vous disiez alors c'est pas
un aboutissement du coup une étape
supplémentaire en quoi c'est un peu
impulsé peut-être une dynamique
supplémentaire dans notre parcours vous
avez 17 ans mais en quoi cette médaille
va vous aider pour la suite vous pensez
bah c'est comme une source de motivation
de se dire bah que la prochaine
compétition internationale où je suis
bah il faut que je fasse les mêmes
résultats c'est bien mais mieux c'est
encore c'est un rêve et puis de me dire
que maintenant j'ai ma place et que je
dois m'améliorer pour augmenter de place
et finir premier et rester premier
depuis longtemps que je pourrais voilà
nickel il y en a un qui est heureux bah
c'est vous justement ce que vous le
suivez depuis quelques années exactement
11 12 ans à peu près et j'ai pu voir un
petit peu l'évolution vous a annoncé
comme un crack je m'en souviens la
première fois que que je suis mis au
club des clés souvent on m'a dit accès
c'est un cra qui va remporter plein de
médailles finalement c'est le cas c'est
le cas où vous remportez plusieurs
médailles mais comment vous faites pour
justement garder la tête froide Axel
parce que tout le monde vous en sens
tout le monde dit que vous êtes un crack
comment on fait pour garder la tête
froide je sais pas c'est j'ai toujours
été comme ça un peu j'ai
pour moi les les médailles c'est ça
représente si une certaine
concrétisation mais voilà sans plus je
me dis que j'ai toujours quelqu'un
derrière moi qui va me rattraper un jour
ou l'autre donc
je pense aussi chroné il est pour
beaucoup aussi dans dans l'encadrement
aussi de de Axel oui je pense que c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des moments aussi
difficiles parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un duo qui qu'on fait la
performance où on passe des moments
difficiles et seulement sont nécessaires
et c'est le moment arriver justement à
chaque fois presque au moment de
l'échéance parce qu'on a besoin de ça
pour pouvoir se voilà mais sinon bah
voilà c'est des petits moments manquent
difficilement la tension sur le truc et
puis maintenant voilà c'est ça roule
comme se déroulait parce qu'on se
connaît super bien on est complémentaire
moi je sais comment il fonctionne c'est
comment fonctionne et puis là la machine
est lancée donc on a plus trop
difficultés à ce niveau là quoi et vous
en tant que coach maintenant c'est quoi
votre message c'est de lui dire
attention maintenant il y a la médaille
d'argent aller chercher il faut aller
faut toujours viser un peu plus haut je
suis honnête que je vais te mettre avec
vous parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que je
ne rejoins jamais envisage ce discours
là maintenant c'est vrai que quand je
vois qu'il a été capable la troisième
marche c'est vrai que maintenant je vais
pas m'arrêter là et j'aimerais je vais
on va tout faire ensemble pour essayer
d'aller
c'est ce qu'on aimerait faire donc voilà
et porter haut les couleurs des
Clayes-sous-Bois aussi
arriver mais en tout cas on l'a dans un
coin de la tête et puis on aimerait bien
que voilà que ça monte crescendo et que
Ben un à une de ses compètes il ira il
revient avec la médaille d'or autour du
cou la médaille d'or justement dans
combien de temps Axel est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a un objectif ah bah si un
objectif si la prochaine compétition
internationale évidemment le but c'est
voilà la gagner après on verra en
fonction de ce qui se passera dans le
temps mais le but c'est la prochaine
compétition internationale la gagner
arrête si c'est pas possible faire mieux
que cette fois et après on verra bien la
suite pour vous il y a une étape de
coupe du monde en Azerbaïdjan c'est ça
absolument du 16 au 20 du 16 au 20
février donc ça c'est là où vous êtes en
pleine préparation vous allez rentrer en
face de préparation voilà ça c'est à
dire qu'on va commencer à tester un
nouveau programme pour pour représenter
en Angleterre dans dans un an donc voilà
s'il y aura plein d'étapes du monde
comme ça qu'on nous permet de voir
comment la le programme passe comment il
est jugé comment il est évalué par les
juges donc voilà
nickel c'est une dernière question où
rappeler peut-être une info parce qu'il
y a un autre membre de du club des
Clayes-sous-Bois effectivement Kevin
Ferreira lui obtenu la 14e place lors
des championnats du monde c'est c'est un
membre également du club des
Clayes-sous-Bois on n'a pas pu
l'accueillir sur sur ce plateau mais on
pense à lui forcément
c'est un jeune qui en fait son histoire
à lui à l'origine il vient du club de
Draveil un club qui a fermé ses portes
donc il est arrivé chez moi à 14 ans
on comprend la porte on sachant que le
club des clip faisait de la performance
son père voulait qu'il fasse la
performance et quand tu vas faire de la
performance d'ailleurs chez nous et
depuis 4 ans il a petit à petit il a il
a grandi les étapes et puis il arrive à
se qualifier l'année dernière au
chocolat du monde par groupe d'âge
installer encore là il a fait une petite
erreur je pense que sa place n'est pas
14e mais c'est le sport le sport est
comme ça et tous les sports sont comme
ça il a fait une petite contref qui a
sorti des finales mais dans l'avenir on
parlera de lui j'en suis sûr bon bravo
tout de même à lui bravo à vous Axel et
bravo coach René et mamie pour cette
médaille de bronze au mondiaux à Sofia
et on continuera bien sûr accès à vos
prochaines performances on espère avec
des médailles d'argent ou d'or voilà
c'est tout le mal qu'on peut vous
souhaiter merci d'être passé en plateau
tous les réseaux on termine Michael
cette page sport avec une dernière
information et une date à retenir pour
les passionnés de cyclisme ce samedi 10
décembre en fin d'après-midi le vélo de
national de 50 ans et demi va accueillir
le gala star en piste un événement qui
réunit depuis 2019 sur la piste 50
chinoise des athlètes de Roland comme
Quentin Lafargue Sébastien vigiou encore
mathildegro la structure et vinoise
ouvrait assez portes dès 17h et le
moment fort sera vers 20h si vous êtes
intéressé et intéressé il reste quelques
places à la vente merci Michael pour
toutes ces précisions